hi welcome back this should be the last
video for the series to look at the
pathway analysis and how we can actually
use the data from drive to identify the
candidate drugs for further testing
okay so in the past server we deal
basically we have explore how we can use
the drive data set
download the drive data set and extract
the information we have also covered for
example how to do the romanization using
the shrnas sake and okay in the most
recent one okay i also show you how to
run the to filter the data using the c
scorecard of RSA or also the rico
analysis now that we have all these okay
a few genes so which each of them could
be a candidate hit but in order for us
to actually identify the drug targets it
would be good that we can actually
collapse all these hits into a possible
pathway and also suggest that andres
that we can test in order to do that
basically in this video i'm going to
travel okay the three things here
including to calculate the mean see
score okay then after that we will use a
top 100 genes from the mean z score and
then to construct the pathway analysis
and also carry on to identify the drug
targets
okay so i'm just going to use the file
that you have uploaded to Dropbox
basically what you have here is you have
the original C score this is after the
shrnas normalization and you also did
you also collapse them into the
calculator the mean for each of the
genes C score we should be very useful
and you also conducted the C score card
of the rigor and also the RS at the RSA
analysis and these are the genes or the
candidate heat that are basically
identified for each cell life so what
I'm going to do now is basically I'm
going to okay create the list for all
the
the genes that you have filtered
basically this will be the hits for all
the sound lines so I'm going to create
that list here
and all you need to do is basically you
are going to copy each of this this
links here into a separate sheet and
then remove the duplicate okay once you
have removed all the duplicate and also
the redundant genes you should have
about two thousand eight hundred and
forty seven genes which is identified as
heat from each cell lines now what I'm
going to do next is basically I'm going
to compare this table with all the cell
lines and also the average C score here
by using the vlookup formula again so
because we look up so this will be my
lookup value and then the range I'm
going to look up for would be from here
all the way to the end okay and then
will be returned from column number
three and forth so then you should get
okay the value here so this this is
basically the what this is basically
their this mean score for this
particular gene of in the PSP c3 so we
are going to do next is basically you
can then use the same formula than to
complete the whole table here so after
it is completed you should get a table
something like this so what I'm going to
do now is basically I'm going to
calculate the mean across all the genes
here so you can see that for the highest
okay for SN our PD one for example
okay the mean C score across all the
cell lines here are basically minus four
point seven so I'm going to do next is
basically I'm just going to sort it from
the smallest to the highest meaning that
basically the lis
here up a fish sorted by the most potent
gene not the most potent gene knockdown
in all the cell lines come okay in the
list that we actually identified and
here what I'm going to do now is busy
I'm going to just select our top 100
genes here okay and then I'm going to
put this place into the pathway and the
disease so for pathway analysis what I'm
going to do now is basically we will use
the online software called string so you
can read up about the basic concept
about string so basically what you need
to do is that you put a input list here
again this is a top 100 genes that we're
not now induce a significant amount of
self growth inhibition in the pancreatic
cancer so we are going to select
organism is Homo sapiens okay so then
you press Continue here and what it does
is basically it will actually generate a
network map to show the relationship
between each of the candidate genes that
you actually identify so an each of this
color line here basically represents
something you can look at the legend
here it will tell you what is the
relationship that is related from one
gene to another so you can as I say
before you can read up more about the
string algorithm it's actually quite
interesting if you want you can also
move the node as you like basically is
an interactive map here now what I'm
going to do next is basically I would go
into the settings so instead of showing
all the evidence lines lines here I'm
just going to be interested to show the
confidence line okay basically in the
confidence lie if I update it what you
will see is basically the darker the
line is the higher the confidence it is
now so you note that basically the
require interaction score by default is
set to zero point four so in this case
here I'm going to increase it to the
high
okay only 0.9 and I'm going to update
the map so now you can see that okay
last of the note I actually connect to
each other you have a lot of the note
that do not connect so now so what does
all this mean is basically you can also
go into the analysis here for example it
will straight away tell you okay what in
in the tech based on the CAC pathway
which of the pathway are particularly
and rich by the gene set that you put it
in here in this case here okay you have
ten genes okay in your list which is
between the spliceosome pathway and when
you select this one here it will
highlight what are those genes you can
see that this is the group of the genes
are related okay in in the spliceosome
pathway and then if you look at the
second hires and signify significance is
basically the proteasome the enrichment
significantly is a proteasome pathway
here and then same go for synaptic
vesicles okay and also the the ribosome
pathway here so the rest of it doesn't
seems to be enriched particularly
significant in the CAC pathway so in
this case here we will conclude that
basically the top-100 candidate genes
that you identify from the drive study
basically if that enriched in the four
pathway here what it means here is
basically okay by inhibiting the
spliceosome proteasome or ribosome in
the solar synaptic vesical cycle there
might be a high potential that you would
be able to target the pancreatic cancer
you
okay so now that we have identified the
four pathway that might be potential for
targeting the next question is basically
what are the dress that we can use to
actually target this pathway and also
the top 10 100 genes that we have
identified so what we are going to do
now is basically we are going to use
another online I'll go read online
database called DG ID B so this is
basically the drug gene interaction
database so what you need to do is
basically you can search the draft gene
interaction by clicking this button here
all right
then you just need to put in the gene
list this is a top 100 genes that you
have identified and then you click on
the find drug gene interactions here
okay so what you can see is that for the
gene as an RPD one there's no known drug
that is targeting it so same go for PR
pf8 for example these are the genes that
have no target to it so when you have
one drug that could target it and if you
click inside here they will tell you the
information about this particular in
drugs basically no so but what is
interesting here is basically you can
see that PSMA 4 which is a proteasome
inhibitors you have a range of port
proteins from inhibitors that could
actually target the the PSMA 4